it's a pleasure to welcome you another
deputy prime minister of dispatch box
the third Deputy that I faced in three
years and you know what they say the
third time times charm
and I'm also pleased to help Mr Speaker
that the Prime Minister as a working
class friend finally
operative seats at last year's local
elections the right honorable gentleman
resigned saying someone must take
responsibility after a thousand more
conservative councilors have been given
the boot by voters who does he think is
responsible now
[Applause]
remarks can I just say it really is a
pleasure to see the right honorable lady
here today I was though expecting to
face the labor leaders choice for the
next Deputy Prime Minister if they win
the election so I'm surprised that the
lib Dem leader isn't taking questions
[Applause]
Mr Speaker
you will forgive me
Mr Speaker you
you will forgive me if I take the right
honorable ladies predictions with a
pinch of salt after all she confidently
predicted that the right honorable
member for Islington North would one day
be prime minister remember this is a man
who wanted to abolish the Army scrap
Trident withdraw from NATO and abandon
Ukraine and what did she say to that she
couldn't wait for him to be prime
minister